nous sommes le vendredi 14 novembre
dernière édition pour cette semaine du
journal de la rédaction merci de nous
rejoindre pour ce nouveau point sur
l'actualité locale et au cours de la
prochaine demi-heure il sera question
notamment de la Journée Mondiale du
Diabète un nombre grandissant de
personnes sont atteintes les
professionnels de la santé les
associations s'inquiètent vous
entendrait notamment le témoignage sur
son quotidien d'un jeune de 7 ans d'une
jeune de 7 ans touché par la maladie ils
viennent de Mantel jolie suivent leurs
études au lycée militaire de saint-cer
l'école une association aide ses jeunes
élèves méritant à intégrer des filières
d'excellence invité du journal pour en
parler négip Gasmi le président de
l'association et puis de l'implication
du laboratoire de Versailles 50 ans dans
la mission Rosetta au déplacement dans
les ivelines derv Mariton pour la
campagne à la présidence de l'UMP fin
novembre retour sur l'essentiel de la
semaine en seconde partie du
journal 31 kg d'emballage ménagé trié en
moyenne par chaque habitant de la région
en Île-de-France c'est moins bien que la
moyenne nationale qui s'établit à 46 kg
éco-emballage vient de diffuser les
chiffres pour 2013 et s'inquiète de
cette situation le dispositif sera donc
renforcé prochainement avec par exemple
des bacs de tri pour les zones d'habitat
où la collecte sélective n'existe pas à
noter aussi que dans les Evelin 56124
tonnes d'emballagees ménager ont été
triés en 2013 une baisse de 1,42 % par
rapport à l'année précédente
le diabète progresse certains parlent
d'épidémie silencieuse du 21e siècle en
France la Haos c'est forte ces 10
dernières années près de 5 % de la
population serait touché par ce trouble
de l'assimilation de l'utilisation et du
stockage des sucres apportés par
l'alimentation en 7ette journée de
mobilisation mondiale l'IPS l'Institut
de promotion de la santé basé à trappe a
proposé une journée de dépistage il faut
savoir qu'il existe deux types de
diabète il peut-être de type 1 et touche
plutôt les jeunes il se traite par un
apport d'insuline au corps ou encore de
type 2 chez les personnes de plus de 40
ans surpoids obésité manque d'activité
physique en sont les causes révélatrices
de ce diabète de type 2 chez des sujets
qui sont en général génétiquement
prédisposés aujourd'hui en fait dans la
société on a une une un diabète de type
2 qui a une proportion plus importante
que le diabète de type 1
puisqueaujourd'hui on compte à peu près
85 % de la de des gens diabétiques de
type 1 le diabète de type 2 touche à peu
près 10 % de la population 5 % concerne
les autres types de diabète l'importance
de se faire dépister aujourd'hui c'est
de prévenir toutes les complication lié
au diabète nous savons que aujourd'hui
un diabétique de type 2 peut être dans
cet état pendant des années sans être
dépisté les complications peuvent être
dramatiques le diabète attaque en
général tout ce qui est nerf et
vaisseaux sanguin et les complications
sont d'ordre souvent neurologique et
cardiologique
on parle de de laavc mais on parle
également de l'infarctus du
myocarde je vous propose d'écouter à
présent le témoignage de Lola marlee
Leroi elle n'a que 7 ans elle est
atteinte depuis l'âge de 2 ans par un
diabète de type 1 elle nous explique
avec sa maman Nadège comment elle vit la
maladie au
quotidien parfois j'ai j'ai envie de
rester autant de temps que je à la
piscine manger plein de trucs plein de
bonbons parce que j'adore ça mais sinon
ça va et pourquoi tu peux pas rester
longtemps à la piscine bah parce que
sinon ma gcéie est trop élevée d'accord
parce que tu as une pompe oui voilà et
quand elle se baigne on doit débrancher
la pompe d'accord pour qu'elle puisse se
baigner et donc on peut débrancher la
pompe environ 1 heure 1 heure et
de et ensuite la rebrancher donc voici
la pompe à
insuline qui est relié par une tubulure
à un t TER qui est sur le haut de la
fesse qui doit être changé deux à trois
fois par semaine c'est bon chéri et donc
à l'intérieur de cette pompe vous avez
un petit réservoir avec l'insuline donc
de l'insuline qui
est qui passe toute la journée en
continu comme notre propre pancréas en
fait excusez-moi et au moment des
repas au moment des repas nous
effectuons une injection grâce à la
pompe ce qui évite d'utiliser une
seringue ou ou un stylo à insuline comme
d'autres ont beaucoup hop tiens et ça te
dérange toi Lola tu le tu le sens tu non
ça me dérange pas elle a l'habitude
c'est vrai qu'on la pique sur le haut de
la fesse elle a pris l'habitude de faire
attention à la tubulure c'est toujours
accroché à sa ceinture bon parfois elle
a des moments de ralbol hein ça la gêne
elle a pas envie l'été sous une robe ça
la contrarie parfois un petit peu au
niveau esthétique mais sinon non on va
dire qu'elle est plutôt à l'aise avec ça
comme elle dit je pense que ce qui est
difficile c'est parfois la frustration
et de ne pas se sentir exactement comme
les autres mais elle peut faire tout
autant que les autres elle peut manger
comme les autres tout est une question
d'équilibre finalement un enfant
diabétique peut manger comme n'importe
quel autre enfant et tous les gens tout
le monde devrait manger en fait comme
quelqu'un diabétique c'est-à-dire
équilibré manger de tout
et et la pompe c'est un gros confort un
gros confort pour découvrir
l'intégralité de ce témoignage
rendez-vous à partir de lundi sur notre
antenne pour un nouveau numéro du
mensuel checkup mensuel de la santé
préparé par yolen Torz l'invité du
journal en ce vendredi négip Gasmi
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes le
président de l'association ei APIC
association qui aide des jeunes élèves
méritant intégré des filières
d'excellence réaliser à plusieurs ce qui
n'est pas envisageable seul c'est votre
devise expliquez nous comment on met ça
en pratique tout à fait en fait
l'association
APIC existe depuis maintenant 27 ans
elle intervient sur le quartier du
valfouret depuis donc 27 ans et nous
avons ce qu'on appelle un agrément Dans
le cadre du Contrat Local
d'Accompagnement à la scolarité qui
concerne essentiellement les enfants qui
ont des difficultés ou qui n'ont pas les
moyens adéquates à la maison pour
pouvoir faire leur scolarité de manière
normale donc on est sur comment
accompagner les enfants les ouvrir à un
éveil pour qu'ils puissent réussir leur
scolarité donc ça c'est le le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que euh
l'outil enfin leur cœur de métier qui
est le classe le Contrat Local
d'Accompagnement à scolarité nous permet
d'evrer sur tout domaines la parentalité
mais aussi euh ce qu'on appelle bah les
élèves qui sont méritant entre
guillemets qui ont des capacités mais
qui n'ont pas l'information nécessaire
pour pouvoir accéder à des grandes
écoles telleles que saint-cir euh donc
sur l'école Saint- on a eu
l'information en 2013 enfin 2012 pardon
fin 2012 qu' levait la possibilité pour
les élèves qui avaient un certain niveau
de pouvoir accéder à ces grandes écoles
via le contrat enfin ce qu'ils appelent
le plan fadéamara pour les plan Espoir
banlieu donc depuis 2008 donc 2008- 2012
4 ans 4 ans de perdu puisque aucun élève
de mant la Jolie n'a pu y accéder et
donc VI monsieur Semama de du sirfa de
manjolie qui s'étonnait justement de ne
pas voir d'élèves de Man jolie accéder à
ces grandes écoles il a rencontré la
directrice de la politique de la ville à
Man la jolie madame elamrati qui nous a
dit que ce serait peut-être intéressant
de pouvoir travailler avec ces jeuneslà
et de pouvoir les amener vers
l'excellence donc vous avez réussi à
faire à les faire rentrer dans cet
établissement on va venir dans un
instant on va même voir une vidéo que
vous avez réalisé à cette à cette
occasion un extrait d'une vidéo
puisqu'elle est elle dure à peu près 5
minutes elle est visible sur Internet
vous l'avez posté récemment juste par
rapport à au résultat que vous avez
obtenu depuis 1987 vous qui intervenez
auprès DEES ces élèves ces jeunes qui
sont dans un milieu pas toujours évident
vous êtes satisfait du bilan quels sont
les exemples qu'on peut mettre en avant
écoutz on est on est quand même sur à
peu près 450 enfants par an donc c'est
environ 350 familles qui différentes qui
viennent qui sollicitent un petit peu
cet accompagnement donc quand on nous
parle parfois de parents des
missionnaire j'ai envie de rire un petit
peu même beaucoup parce que on a
effectivement des parents qui sont
soucieux de la réussite de leurs enfants
et qui viennent et qui sollicitent cet
accompagnement donc en 27 ans nous avons
vu des enfants qui ont bénéficier de
l'accompagnement la scolarité au sein de
l'association et qui sont devenus par la
suite accompagnateurs qui ont fait de
grandes écoles nous en avons eu qui ont
fait sence po par exemple d'autres qui
ont fait fini avocat et qui aujourd'hui
nous soutiennent dans nos actions
quotidiennes comment vous situez par
rapport à l'éducation national c'est un
partenaire ou alors vous avez le
sentiment aussi d'intervenir là où il y
a un échec là où le système classique ne
fonctionne pas par pas du tout d'échec
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes un
partenaire nous sommes une continuité de
ce que fait l'école et sans l'école on
peut rien faire on n'est pas dans de
l'apprentissage l'apprentissage c'est
l'école qui le fait nous nous sommes le
plus qui va permettre à un enfant qui a
des difficultés à acquérir cet
apprentissage au sein de l'entité
scolaire de pouvoir par d'autres
activités telles que le théâtre les jeux
et cetera c'est pas dommage de se dire
que à l'intérieur de l'école ça n'est
pas possible et qu'il faut
l'intervention de structure comme la
vôtre par exemple non je pense pas
qu'ilut je crois en on peut pas
fonctionner en en disant l'école ne
réussit pas et les associations
réussissent je crois que c'est c'est
tout un partenariat qui existe c'est
comme l'école et les parents si les
parents n'agissent pas au niveau de
l'éducation des enfants ça peut pas
fonctionner c'est c'est un tout et
heureusement qu'il y a cette ouverture
et que l'éducation nationale joue le jeu
du partenariat euh pour celles qui le
jouent parce qu'il y en a qui ne le
jouent pas pour celles qui le jouent on
a des réussites on va regarder cet
extrait de de vidéo dont on parlait il y
a un instant visible sur Internet
Internet le nom de cette vidéo j'ai un
projet donc je suis vous l'avez réalisé
pour présenter le parcours de quatre
élèves des collèges de montes qui sont
aujourd'hui au lycée militaire C élèves
licée militaire et internat d'excellence
de Marle loroist si même on regarde
cette
vidéo
[Musique]
voilà donc de retour en plateau après
cet extrait de de vidéo réalisé par
l'association APIC son président qui est
en plateau pour parler de ce travail
d'accompagnement parlez-nous de ces
jeunes donc ils ne sont pas quatre comme
je disais tout à l'heure mais bien si
avoir bénéficié alors pardon euh
en 2012 quand le le militaire vient voir
la politique de la ville nous avons eu
cinq jeunes qui ont fait l'entraînement
entre guillemets la préparation à
l'entrée à l'école de saint-sire parce
que c'est ouvert aux jeunes qui sont en
ZEP en ZUS Z urbaine sensible et qui
sont boursiers donc sur les CIN jeunes
les CIN ont réussi le le
concours malheureusement une n'était
plus boursière donc elle ne pouvait plus
y accéder et le dernier était sur liste
d'attente donc nous en avons eu trois en
20132 14 donc déjà bon résultat pour un
premier parce que sur Saint- cire c'est
15 % d'ouvert aux jeunes qui sont dans
les zones sensibles donc trois sur
l'année
2013 2000 enfin 2014 2015 nous en avons
eu 6 donc en préparation donc c'est une
préparation des jeunes mais aussi des
parents parce que il faut les préparer
enfin préparer les parents à ce que
leurs enfants aillent en internat donc
du lundi au vendre du dimanche soir
pardon au vendredi euh les préparer les
enfants aussi à ne plus manger à midi à
la maison que le soir c'est c'est autre
chose donc il y a une préparation via
des bénévoles au sein de l'association
donc c'est une préparation mathématique
anglais français plus du coaching
individuel sur on n'est plus dans le
même rythme là comme vous pouvez le voir
dans le film c'est c'est un uniforme
c'est c'est l'armée donc c'est le
drapeau et et comment ils le vivent
justement quel retour vous en avez ils
sont pleinement satisfait l'adaptation
était difficile alors on les revoit
enfin ils viennent tous les vendredis
quand ils finissent la première chose
qu'ils font ils rentrent pas à la maison
ils viennent nous voir à l'association
pour nous dire comment ils ont vécu les
choses que ça a été super pour eux bon
parfois difficile parce qu'effectivement
on est confronté à un are milieu on leur
envoie pas automatiquement des choses
positives la fierté qu'ils ont c'est
qu'ils ont réussi le concours donc on
peut pas leur dire vous êtes les enfants
des cités donc vous êtes rentrés parce
que vous avez du un vous avez réussi ils
ont réussi le concours au même niveau
que n'importe quel lequel des enfants
qui est donc c'est super positif et puis
bon effectivement tivement la séparation
avec la famille parfois c'est un petit
peu difficile mais dans l'espoir enfin
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucun élève qui
a dit j'arrête quels sont les plus
grandes difficultés qu'il rencontre
justement pour pour s'intégrer en tout
cas pour passer ses concours quelles
sont les les lacunes qu'ils ont et sur
lesquelles vous devez intervenir
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur quelle est
la marche la plus dure nous on reprend
tout avec c'està dire toutes les enfin
au niveau de on a la chance d'avoir des
de très bons bénévoles avec des niveaux
assez élevé que ce soit Fatima qui est
la coordinatrice de l'association Farida
Fabien qui ingénieur qui nous a aidé au
niveau de tout ce qui est mathématique
ou Mariam qui est à science pour et qui
intervient sur le coaching euh on remet
avec eux on retravaille sur toutes les
bases enfin les bénévoles retravaillent
avec eux sur toutes les bases à savoir
bah comment se présenter comment être le
langage quartier langage saciè c'est
plus le même donc il y a toute cette
adaptation et on voit le changement
c'est c'est phénoménal c'està dire que
le sur la première la première j'ai
envie de dire équipe qui est de 2013 on
a V très rapidement le changement et et
ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ces jeuneslà sont des
porte-parole pour les autres jeunes sur
le quartier en disant nous aussi on y
est vous aussi vous pouvez y aller et
leurs ambitions aujourd'hui justement à
ces jeunes qui sont qui ont intégré ces
ces structures d'excellence ils veulent
aller encore plus haut ils ont des des
projets oui justement c'est c'est ça
leura deedonneré confiance pour l'avenir
aussi c'est ce que j'appellerai moi
enfin nous on l'appelle cette opération
faisons rêver nos jeunes c'est qu'à un
moment donné ces jeunes ne rêvent plus
donc à partir du moment vous leur donner
la possibilité d'accéder à quelque chose
auquel personne ne croyait puisque on
parlait tout à l'heure d' l'éducation
nationale sur les six établissements
malheureusement deux ont joué le jeu et
depuis cette année on en a un 3oè donc
voilà c'était à partir du moment où vous
donnez cette confiance à l'individu et
au jeunes en lui disant tu es capable
d'y arriver ça rentre dans le chemin et
donc du coup il y croit et donc il peut
faire croire aux autres aussi que ça
marche non seulement il y croit il est
arrivé et donc donc les ambitions sont
toutes autres et votre ambition pour
conclure sur l'association c'est
d'ouvrir encore plus d'établissement
d'accueillir encore plus de jeunes de
s'ouvrir sur le reste du département
puisque vous intervenez sur sur mon mais
on est on est très on est très humble au
niveau de l'association on fait avec les
moyens que l'on peut si on peut
accueillir plus d'enfants pour leur
permettre de rêver un peu plus ce serait
magnifique vous êtes ble et vous me
l'avez dit tout à l'heure je vais le
répéter avant de passer en plateau vous
préférez l'action à la médiatisation
mais merci d'être venu sur le plateau
pour nous parler de votre travail merci
à vous avant de passer pour la suite de
ce journal à l'essentiel de la semaine
je vous donne le bilan du contrôle
routier que nous avions évoqué hier dans
le journal avec 18 points de contrôle
dans les ivelines et la présence de 81
policiers 334 véhicules arrêtés un total
de 47 infractions à noté aussi 6
interpellations pour dont cinq pour des
lit routiers et deux personnes ont aussi
été placées en Gard à
vue retour donc à présent comme chaque
vendredi sur l'essentiel de la la
semaine avec tout d'abord la mission
Rosetta qui a permis au robot fila et
vous le savez d'atterrir sur cette
comète chourri le robot qui malgré une
position actuellement plutôt délicate
transmet de nombreuses informations à la
communauté spatiale européenne
l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin est responsable de
l'installation de plusieurs des
instruments il a ouvert ses portes au
public pour retransmettre en direct
l'événement Mélanie poet et lodim moine
qui étaient sur
place enfin filae s'est posé sur chour
20 ans l'attendait la mission est
approuvée par le comité de programme
scientifique de l'ESA en
1993 mais Rosetta n'est lancé que le 2
mars 2004 ici à Guill encour cet
atterrissage est marquant le premier
sentiment c'est
l'émotion de voir une une entreprise qui
était singulière et qui était la
première de ce type là réussir une
récompense des gens qui ont travaillé
depuis très très longtemps et et qui là
voit voit le fruit euh euh se réaliser
de le leurs efforts et puis et puis donc
voilà mis en lumière le le travail des
gens sur sur cette mission qui est qui
est emblématique le Latmos laboratoire
atmosphère milieu observation spatiale a
participé à l'élaboration de 7 des 20
instruments présents à bord de Rosetta
et filae et notamment concert un sondeur
présent sur l'orbiteur et sur le robot
c'est un travail international donc
toutes les données seront échangés entre
les les les gens qui sont impliqués
l'enjeu pour nous c'est c'est de
comprendre comment c'est constitu une
comète et après queles sont les gazes
qui qui s'échappent de cette comète et
qui la composent pour effectivement
comprendre quel a pu être le rôle de ces
objets l'atterrissage n'a pas été
parfait filae a finalement rebondi pour
atterrir à 1 km de sa cible et n'a pas
réussi à déclencher ses harpon il se
trouverait sur une pente fortement
inclinée le manque d'ensoleillement
pourrait aussi écourter son
fonctionnement mais pour le moment le
robot fonctionne bien l'aventure doit se
conclure le 31 décembre
2015 politique lundi après Nicolas
Sarkozi Bruno leemer nous revenion sur
ce déplacement d'Hervé Mariton qui
poursuit sa campagne pour la présidence
de l'UMP dans les ivelines le scrutin
interne au parti qui va se dérouler le
29 novembre depuis Versailles celui que
les sondages créditent d'à peine 1 %
s'est montré plutôt incisif
écoutez petit Pousset face à degliat
HERV Mariton onend prouvé au mil UMP que
sa candidature est une alternative
crédible face à Nicolas Sarkozi et Bruno
Le Maire ce dimanche matin sur le marché
de Versailles avant de rencontrer les
journalistes il a avant tout souhaité
réaffirmer qu'il était le seul à avoir
un discours clair vous avez parfois dans
la vie politique et je le constate il
compris de mes concurrents une
tentation de dire les choses de manière
contournée pas de manière tout à fait
droite parce que certains pensent que
l'ambiguïé permet de rassembler plus de
voix moi je crois que l'ambiguïté
aujourd'hui est mauvaise conseillère moi
je suis clair je suis carré je suis
probablement moins connu que mes deux
concurrents mais je pense être plus
intense dans les
convictions un discours sans ambigué sur
les 35 heures qu'il souhaite supprimer
tout comme la loi tobira ou encore sur
la justice lui qui défend le retour de
la double peine abrogé par Nicolas
Sarkozi l'actuel député de la Drome a
reçu dans les ivelines le soutien du
conseiller général Olivier de laaffa à
l'origine de sa venue aujourd'hui l'UMP
souffre souffre de son projet on ne voit
plus de projet on voit des hommes qui V
un coup à gauche un coup à droite ch
change d'opinion un peu en fonction du
temps je crois qu'aujourd'hui on a
surtout besoin d'avoir des hommes qui
ont une qui créent cette ligne
directrice c'est ce que fait le frond
national et malheureusement à l'UMP on
n'est pas capable de faire ça également
présent sur ce déplacement à Versailles
Gérard Larché sénateur des Yveline
président du Sénat il se dit neutre même
s'il a rappelé qu'avant de changer de
nom l'UMP devait surtout se doter d'un
programme je pense qu'il faut refonder
notre projet parce que nous ne sommes
plus en 2002 on est face à une France
qui aujourd'hui n'a plus deroiss S qui
est un chômage de masse qui traverse une
crise morale et cette crise morale la
question de la famille par exemple est
au cœur de cette crise morale faut donc
rebâtir un projet c'est beaucoup plus
important qu'un nom les militants se
prononceront le 29 novembre sur le nom
de leur nouveau
président et puisque nous parlons
politique c'est ce weekend que nous vous
proposons un nouveau numéro de café
politique invité François de Ligier le
maire de Guill encour il reviendra sur
son parcours également conseiller
général socialiste desiveline il
évoquera sa candidature les risques pour
sa formation de subir un nouveau revers
rendez-vous ce weekend devant votre télé
ou sur internet pour les replay nous en
parlerons lundi en revanche c'est ce
weekend que se déroule le premier forum
de la réussite de Manil les amo et fait
original c'est à l'initiative de
l'opposition UMP du conseil municipal il
s'était engagé à mettre en place ce
rendez-vous autour de l'orientation
professionnelle pour les étudiants et
les personnes en reconversion ce sera
donc samedi 15 novembre à partir de 10h
opô Blaise Pascal à
Manil nous poursuivons ce journal de
vendredi avec une rencontre celle de
Omar Youssef Souleiman auteur syrien
avec des jeunes de Guill en cours tous
les ans des dizaines d'écrivains sont
persécutés la Maison de la poésie de sa
Quentin sensibilise libère la parole à
l'occasion de ce type de
moment je ne suis plus personne c'est le
nom de son poème exprimé ici dans sa
langue arabe Omar Youssef Souleiman
parle notamment de son exil de sa vie
d'avant chez lui en Syrie et de sa vie
d'aujourd'hui à Montreuil auparavant
journaliste syrien il a été traqué et
surveillé dans son pays à l'occasion de
la Semaine des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés et empêchés il est venu à la
rencontre des collégiens guon courtois
j'ai expliqué qu'est qu se passait avec
moi en Syrie comment les comment on a
organisé les manifestations comment les
armées entréent dans la Syrie comment
les islamiques est venu après car on n
pas on éétait pas des islamiques au
début de de les manifestation voilà
c'est pour ça c'est c'est important il
allait avoir 20 24 ans quand la
Révolution a commencé en mars 2011 en
Syrie un an plus tard ne trouvant plus
sa place dans la guerre civile
religieuse il décide de passer la
frontière et de rejoindre la France une
histoire qui interpelle les élèves quand
on écoute son histoire en fait c'est
c'est toujours parce que c'est des
choses qu'on entend pas au quotidien
qu'est-ce qui t'a touché
particulièrement dans son histoire bah
c'est quand il s'est quand il est venu
en France en fait quand il est parti de
la Syrie j'ai appris des choses quoi par
exemple comme quoi avait poêt qu'
pouvait pas exprimer ce qu'il pensait
toute la semaine des écrivains du monde
entier vont à la rencontre des
collégiens lycéens et étudiants évlinois
pour témoigner de leur histoire et
comment avons-nous dormi et le 15
novembre une soirée à la maison de la
poésie de Guyon courour et proposer la
parole sera donnée à des écrivains des
artistes syriens qui ont connu dans leur
pays la persécution pour des faits
d'écriture ou qui défendent de leur exil
la parole des écrivains de rendez-vous à
vous donner pour ce weekend également de
refermer ce journal tout d'abord
l'opération good Evelin qui se poursuit
après le lancement à Versailles le
weekend dernier la liste des restaurants
et des animations sur le site de
l'opération des rendez-vous dédiés au
saveurs local notamment proposés samedi
dimanche à la distillerie du noyau de
poissie à la bergerie national ou chez
le chocolatier franc debos à Montini le
Bretonneux et puis toujours autour de la
gastronomie le salon vin saveur et
couleurs de morpa 45 exposants
viticulteur producteurs artisan à partir
de 11h le samedi c'est organisé par
l'association caritative le lyonce club
les bénéfices du salon vont donc
permettre de financer des actions de
bienfaisance pour un point complet sur
les idées sorties des prochains jours
rendez-vous juste après ce journal avec
yolen Torres pour le 78 weekend quant à
moi je vous retrouve lundi 18h toujours
en direct pour un point complet sur
l'actualité
locale